welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Naro filling in for Eric Voss
while he is out on paternity leave yay
Eric and this is a breakdown of the 10th
and final episode of season 7 of Rick
and Morty titled fear no Mort this is a
Mindbender of an episode bringing
together plot threads not just from this
season but from the entire series we're
going to break down all the jokes
callbacks and animation details you
might have missed before we get started
make sure you're subscribed to our other
channels the break room and the Deep
dive and as always the best way to
support the channel is by heading over
to nerd rot. shop and grabbing some
sweet pop culture merch Rick and Morty
casually amble through a hellscape that
looks a little like the upside down from
stranger things it turns out they were
in some sort of interplanetary haunted
house looking for Thrills but it's just
not working Morty says this this
Carnival of nightmares used to be scary
right H we've seen too much fighting
against numbness and apathy has been a
big theme this season we've seen Rick
cope with the emptiness he feels after
killing his Nemesis Rick Prime in
episode 5 and in episode 9 Morty says
I'm just sensitized Rick I took took
some kind of test in school and the
counselor had to call Homeland Security
even this spooky Carnival can't make
them feel anything despite how horrible
it is in the background we see a spooky
clown lady above a dunk tank filled with
knives they approach by a suited man
voiced by the star of Ray Donovan leave
shriber who has some serious Rod sirling
Vibes rodling was the creator of The
Twilight Zone and would pop into
episodes to give some creepy context
this dude says he knows a place on Earth
where Rick and Morty can find some
scares we end up at a Denny's this is
the first time Rick and Morty have
visited a real restaurant in the Rick
Shank Redemption they visited a shony
the plot of final dation kicks off when
the family gets some insane fortune
cookies from Panda Express Rick and
Morty think that the suit guy just
tricked them into giving him a ride they
decide to head into Denny's anyway Rick
has an insane order that includes a
lumberjack slam Graham sandwich pancake
puppy slam Burger two milkshakes and an
order of cheddar tots these are all real
Denny's menu items except that the
cheddar tots don't appear to be
available in the United States Denny's
in Indonesia has loaded jalapeno cheddar
tots and Denny's Canada has bacon
cheddar tots I've never been more
jealous of Canada and Indonesia Rick's
chaotic order could be another tactic to
try and feel something via food or
because it's Rick he could just be
fighting a hangover their waiter lets
them know in a very blasé tone that if
they're there for the hole it's in the
men's bathroom there is indeed a spooky
hole in the men's bathroom that looks
just like the entrance to the mirror
cave from The Last Jedi Rick and Morty
the show has never shied away from a
Star Wars reference they even had an
entire episode about a lightsaber this
season's rise of the numeric cons had a
ton including a scene in an Ewok village
and a villain who appeared via hologram
like the Emperor or supreme leader snoke
there's a TV VCR combo in the bathroom
stall that plays an intro video
featuring suit guy entitled how to Hole
according to the video you jump in the
hole and it shows you your worst fears
come out with a new lease on life and
you get your photo on the wall he's
talking about gar rufa or often used for
pedicures as the tape then cuts at the
end we see it distort suit guy in a
really creepy way making us think he's a
demon or manifestation of death or
something the footage that it cuts too
is the end of a commercial featuring
mamar Gaddafi getting a Mountain Dew I
guess someone taped the whole video over
something else Gaddafi was a Libyan
revolutionary who had conflict with the
US in the80s suggesting that this is
when the whole video was made The
Simpsons used him in a similar way when
Bart passed up an even then out ofd
t-shirt of spinal tap kicking him in the
butt Rick is uninterested but Morty
Dives in he's immediately attacked by
some very scary but kind of generic
Shadow monsters Rick jumps in after him
wreck shop and Pops him out of the hole
Rick takes their photo puts it on the
wall next to the photo of the
white-haired guy we saw in the intro
video and two other characters we
haven't seen yet a hipster looking guy
looking terrified and a red-haired woman
looking messed up but kind of ecstatic
back at home the Smith family is
watching cake or fake the is it cake
parody we saw in episode 7 we see that
in this episode instead of a person who
might be cake tied up it's a giant slice
of cake that might actually be a person
a portal opens in the ceiling dropping
in a young Rick and his wife Diane who
Rick has been searching for/ trying to
avenge for the entire series The Young
Rick dies suggesting that they're from a
universe where he dies instead of Diane
the Smith family is terrified but Rick
and Morty stay calm they assume what we
the fans of this show and all its plot
twists probably also assume they're
still in the hole Rick assumes that this
is Morty's Fear playing out that fear
being that if Rick gets Diane back he
won't need Morty anymore Rick offers to
take everyone for ice cream so he can
gather more data Rick gives himself a
daging serum and tries to explain to
everyone that they're not real that this
is all a projection of the whole he
tells them they're all NPCs NPC stands
for non-player character Rick says that
his main quest is trying to get back
with Diane which she's understandably
grossed out by back at home everyone is
mad at Rick Morty suggests that the fear
they're experiencing might actually
belong to Rick that fear being ruining a
second chance with Diane Diane is
sleeping on a pull-out bed in the
Smith's spare room we see a corny life
is rough golf poster that seems like
something Jerry would get a kick out of
Rick sends a singing robot to apologize
to Diane she says she recognizes the
arms on the robot Rick says that they
belong to a robot he was building for
the feds which is how he and Diane first
met he invites her to the zoo with the
family at the zoo summer is in the
middle of a story about Rick exploring a
civilization that lived on one of her
zits I don't think this is a reference
to anything that's ever happened on the
show I like that these jokes are just
suggesting that the Smiths are having
Insane Adventures all the time even when
we're not seeing them Rick and Diane
feed some ducks Rick feeds them some
bread that makes them talk they just
scream at each other this reminds me of
the classic fars side cartoon where a
scientist decodes dog language only to
find out they're just saying hey Rick
says he got the idea for the duck
decoder from Diane's Master's thesis
jewelry is fun right put some sparkly
rings on your fingers and Bam you feel
fancy but engagement rings are next
level that ring is going to be there
forever ever so it's got to be perfect
and you can get your perfect bling at
jamesallen.com jamesallen.com makes
designing custom engagement rings and
Fine Jewelry super easy which I love
because then I can confident say things
like princess cut feels a little ghost
to me I'm more of a marquee cut kind of
gal choose from over 200 100,000
diamonds Conflict Free and either Earth
created or lab created you know the
Steve Rogers versus Captain America type
rocks after you pick your diamond you
can check it out in HD magnified and
zoomed around in 360 like better than
you could if you were at an actual
jewelry store it's wild once you've got
the dime in you like match it with a
metal like Platinum white gold rose gold
yellow gold and one of the hundred other
styles when you're done customizing your
ring at jamesallen.com you'll have the
perfect piece of jewelry for yourself
and you'll have saved up to 50% compared
to traditional retailers if you're not
the customiz in type no judgment
jamesallen.com also has a ton of fine
jewelry pieces all jewelry from
jamesallen.com comes with a lifetime
warranty free resizing and Engraving and
hassle-free 30-day returns I eat that up
jamesallen.com has already been part of
over 200,000 engagements around the
world and yours could be next customize
your engagement ring or jewelry piece
today with James Allen and get 25% off
by clicking the link in the description
go ahead click on it they go to grab a
drink at an alien bar we see that the
bartender is keeping track of the shots
they're taking for some kind of contest
we see slark is in first place followed
by Rick Diane glar and then a few
competitors whose names are written in
an alien language we've met glar before
in the episode one crew over the kuku's
nest the shot contest reminds me of the
one from Raiders of the Lost AR Diane
then says oh when did you stop being a
lightweight kept looking for my wife at
the bottom of a bottle it's nuts to
think about Rick as a lightweight I
guess the hard partying Rick we know was
born when Diane died Rick and Diane kiss
in the rain despite the fact that they
both recently puked that's love baby
back at home Rick is looking sharp in a
suit but has spooky looking bags under
his eyes we also see toothpaste
deodorant and some other hygiene
products Rick has clearly been spiffing
up for Diane Morty is concerned that the
hole is feeding on Rick Rick brushes him
off so he and Diane can go to show biz
Pizza this is of course the competitor
to Chuck E cheeses that features an
animatronic bear Rick is excited to see
Morty goes back to the Denny's he and
the suit guy argue about the nature of
fear Love and Death suit guy refuses to
let more Morty go because the hole needs
to feed on Rick's fear Morty returns to
the house and starts facing all his
fears in order to please the hole he
puts a spider in his mouth and it does
nothing he realizes his greatest fear is
not being accepted he heads to high
school and proceeds to humiliate himself
he hands a bully a note that says top
five things Morty likes about Jessica
one the smell of her gym shoes two the
way she says succulent three her name
means foresight in Hebrew four her skin
is so pretty it makes my wiener hurt
don't nobody take that clip out of
context of me just saying that the bully
teases him because he only had four
entries in his top five list what a
dummy Morty does a trust fall in front
of some cool kids he then volunteers
himself for a school play called three
days of rain and lies about knowing the
lines this is an actual play from the
'90s that shares a name with an
unrelated movie from the early 2000s and
I wish Eric Voss we're here for this
next bit Rick and Diane compare how lost
ended in their respective universes Rick
got the same ending that we did but
Diane says Jack lock and Sawyer teamed
up to kill a fog monster and everyone
got rescued it was one season long and
it was perfect television I for one
loved all six seasons and the finale of
lost but I get it I get it it's like
Rick says you can be great or you can be
around forever possibly commentary on
the 100 episode deal of Rick and Morty
itself maybe I don't know Diane then
starts to glitch out and Rick realizes
that Morty is trying to disrupt the
whole back at school Morty jumps up on
stage for the school play naked we see
that the hole has made him very
emaciated looking Rick realizes that by
keeping him and Morty in the hole it's
killing them both Rick goes on stage
naked himself tells a convenient DJ that
happens to be on the side of the stage
to drop a beat and they perform a rap
that's like a Bizarro naked version of
get schwifty from season 2 I don't know
how to rap I don't know how to rhyme I
don't know how to rap now eat my
this seems to do the trick the scene
Fades away and Diane waves goodbye they
climb out of the hole only to find out
that they're still in the hole they
confess fear after fear to each other
and each time we see that they haven't
actually climbed out of the hole they
decide that uncertainty might be the
fear they need to conquer and just walk
away back at home they admit they don't
actually know if they're still in the
hole or not Rick goes off to get drunk
and Morty go goes up to his room we see
a music montage of Rick and Morty
gradually accepting that they may or may
not be in their old reality we see some
clips of wouldbe classic Adventures like
Rick making a beer cloning machine
running from some aliens while carrying
crystals hot wirring the car mid crash
laughing at what's probably
interdimensional cable we see Morty go
off to college and eventually graduate
both Beth and clone Beth are at both
events Rick and Morty Get Drunk Together
in a bar Morty looks like the
26-year-old version of himself we saw in
Rick marai Jack he's in awesome shape
here and looking great with a little
stubble looks like Morty has what might
be a tribal tattoo on his right arm what
a DK we see Jerry helping Morty move
using a uto truck with the adorable toe
mascot that we saw in the Rick Shank
Redemption summer Mary's a handsome
looking dude it seems like the Smiths
are the only people sitting on her side
brick is passed out while the beths
drink wine regular Beth sips out of a
glass while space Beth pounds right from
the bottle interesting that we don't see
Jerry in this moment maybe he died or
doesn't approve of the marriage for some
reason Morty gets yelled at in an office
while Rick injects anti aging serum like
a junkie we see that he's balding and
has a wig made to look like his Classic
Hair Morty buys a house and reveals via
bathroom mirror that he has turned into
his dad he does indeed look just like
Jerry in this shot and we smash cut to
reveal he's been in the hole the whole
time no word play Morty the show has
done similar a life in a series of
moments montages most recently in that's
amort this season both episodes are
credited to the hilarious writer Heather
and Campbell she does an awesome video
game podcast called get played where one
of the segments is a dive into her retro
Hardware titled Heather's hole
connections we love them great job
Heather that's a Mor wof what an episode
back at the hole entrance Rick says
something that makes Morty realize what
his fear was the entire time no we're
Rick and Morty I'm not leaving without
you Morty realizes his fear is that Rick
doesn't actually feel like that that he
wouldn't come in the hole after Morty it
makes sense that Morty would feel like
this he seen countless clones of himself
and in many cases those clones are
heartlessly killed Rick constantly
places him in dangerous situations and
he feels expendable when he tells this
to Rick his mouth gapes and we hear this
suit guy say thank you for visiting the
fear hole Morty your fear of relying on
Rick has been delicious this seems to do
it Morty wakes up not in a Dark Void but
in a gross looking sewer he sees Rick a
few feet up proving that his fear was
real Rick didn't actually come in after
him Morty seems at peace with all this
he gives Rick a big hug kind of like the
one we saw him give the blood covered
Rick after he killed Rick Prime he pulls
back because he doesn't want to know if
he's still in the hole or not they head
back to the dining room but Rick runs
back in again he considers going in the
hole presumably because Diane might be
in there but he doesn't we could see
this as Rick choosing to move on to stop
the search for Dian he reaches into his
wallet and pulls out a picture of Morty
to tack on the board and yes it's
adorable that he carries around Morty's
picture in his wallet a sign that he
does in fact consider Morty
Irreplaceable for our post-credit scene
we go to Mr Poopy but hole shaving it
what looks like a dumpster he was the
focus of the post-credit scene for the
season 6 finale and the cold open of
this season so it's kind of like Mr
Poopy but hole is guiding us through the
story story at this point he portals
into another reality where he's still
with his wife and kid you'll remember
his wife left them for a predator in
episode one he knocks out the other
version of him tosses him into the
portal and assumes his place at the
table on the wall we see a family photo
montage featuring not just Mr Poopy
butthole and his wife and his kid but
the Smith family too his wife brings him
a beer but we cut out on her suspicious
look and that's it for season seven of
Rick and Morty Eric Voss is going to be
back from baby town before you know it
I've been Hector Naro thank you so much
be sure to check out my other YouTube
channel called Heroes reform forged we
just did a cooking special where I had
to cook for my friends and I don't know
how to cook it's a lot of fun thanks so
much for watching see you guys later
bye